[Music]
so
this tick-tocker was kicked off
poppers rockers
and but people all around the world was
kicked off of tick tock not because she
lives in what looks like a prison
but because um by the way you have such
a small place and you decide you know
what i also need
piano so she was kicked off because she
was
basically making soft core porn videos
you know kind of like
okay okay but there's like isn't that
most of tick-tock is it most of
tick-tock just
furries and like weird horny postings
you're thinking of twitch too
no but tick-tock is very i watch enough
ap
i watch enough cringe talk to see all
the creepy
like pedo [ __ ] furries and [ __ ] i'm
not allowed to talk anymore
because i don't deserve to have feelings
i am an
object well at least she she knows what
she is
oh yeah she made a song about it they
forced you to shave yes
because i'm not a female who deserves
respect i'm just an object
they took this down for nudity
but i can only see your face oh no
that's way too much
i need to cover up oh my god no that's
actually a good idea you're pretty ugly
oh no he's trying to creepy men are
literally scanning the upper house yeah
you know you're a real uh ugga
maybe you shouldn't want so many pickup
artists bro should you just hang around
here
you're not gonna find another guy yeah
you need to make sure that you're not
wearing a bra
so they can hit that report button for
nudity
of course these are not you're right
you're right because e thoughts are the
most oppressed people on the internet
right now
normal body parts it's my fault right no
it's all my fault no yes it's not your
fault at all
but it is they even took a video of me
down where
talked about as a because of hate speech
hate speech
oh no it's happening now wow imagine if
it would have [ __ ] cared when it was
happening to people like us
what you are joking right i'm not
allowed to talk anymore
i'm not allowed to talk because i don't
deserve to have feelings
i am an officer wait did they just did
they just double it yeah for the
ad revenue i
you know what you may be right let me
see just repeated are you
really i promise oh no there are things
happening on tick tock i am scared to
talk about
sadly i was not joking i've been
objectified and punished for it since i
was three years have you tried not being
um how's she gonna make money good point
frankly
i had enough i am imprisoned can't post
comment or go live and i don't care
if you hate or like me in front of your
eyes
an innocent woman gets discriminated
only for being
female that's what it was just because
she was female
that's why if you notice there's no
females on tick tock anymore
they kicked them all off recently did
they really
yeah there's no more time i don't know
that now it's only pedophiles okay
they changed the name to only pedophiles
okay
i deserve to have choice over my body i
deserve to speak about my experiences
with
s.a i don't need to what's essay sexual
assault
okay i thought i was living in san
antonio which probably is worse
and i mean no i i think you're right
sweetheart i think that you are
um within your rights to discuss and
tell your story in great detail if you
need to about your sexual assault like
you could
right now if you want to recount that
story
with as many details as possible slowly
but every time you get to describing the
assailant just describe me instead
she actually got in a car with somebody
from minnesota
he told me he was an auditor he said he
was a citizen journalist
he showed me his penis it was very small
to wear a bra all the time to sum up
i deserve to exist he pulled his penis
out and some of his pubes were actually
taller
than his penis need help
thank you for watching are we going to
help her
i'm not going to say anything
you don't want to help
let's see do you want to watch some of
her other videos
so we could see what she actually does
on tick tock
you know it's always funny to me
i'll just i'll just throw it away i'm
always amused by women who are naturally
pretty
that don't have like a drop of sexiness
to them right
you are awkward yeah yeah exactly what
you mean not even just awkward like the
awkwardness doesn't out but just
everything about him is just not sexy
does she have armpit hair probably
no no it looks like she just hasn't you
know
looks like she's shaved just been a
couple days you know goes course
this is important she said she's talking
about important things in these videos
and i think that
we should do everything we can to defend
her there's nothing funnier than a
really gorgeous woman who's
[ __ ] not sexy at all it's very funny
yeah
dub says smashable i'm not saying that
non-sexy women
aren't [ __ ] men will [ __ ] men will
[ __ ] anything
all right men will [ __ ] you know fat
women
cripples [ __ ] their own mothers
apparently
so i mean you know guys well that's not
true because that's a woman but
um you know i'm not saying that if
they're not sexy they're not still
smashing what i'm just saying
i've met a lot of women in my life that
were pretty but just there was not an
ounce of
anything sensual to them and you're like
how is that possible
you're just a really pretty ah
i was right why is this graphic content
because it's gross i'm sorry to tell you
but women
are not objects we are not existing to
be pleasurable to men
to women or society well obviously given
your track record in the last four years
seriously hi guys we don't exist to be
pleasurable to men while she doesn't
even video where she's
her video without a bra where she shows
her cleavage to make money yeah you know
you're not an object for men but the
minute you stopped being an object for
men you'll lose your [ __ ]
sense of worth trust me sweetheart i've
seen it a hundred times
you're gonna hit the wall in a couple of
years and men aren't going to pay
attention anymore and then you're going
to become a feminist
you're going to double down on the
feminism and then it's going to be
why why are these or you're going to
become one of those
ultra crazy religious people that wants
to shut down only fans because
other women are getting attention now
you'll find some sort of
government or or ngo apparatus to
enforce your angry world
view because men stop paying it's this
is what white women are
white women are miserable for [ __ ] 30
years of their life
pissing and moaning about how all men
are just [ __ ] oh man wants sex and
all these men pay attention to me
and then you all hit 30 and then all you
do after that is piss and moan about how
[ __ ] other women are now getting
objectified by men
shut it enjoy it while you got it you
dumb
there's two reasons why tick-tock banned
me number one
they did not ban you for that and number
two
there's no way they banned her for
armpit hair there's no
[ __ ] way apparently in this society
just existing as a woman is bad or not
somebody's asking how big is that room
30 40 square feet it is tiny
tick-tock did not ban her
for her armpit hair of course they
didn't royce uh i'm going to let you in
on a little secret white women lie
about everything give me one example no
about everything
okay i don't know tell me something a
white woman sold you today it was a lie
okay well uh you're right saki's up
there lying every [ __ ] minute every
god damn day
well before i read this before we can go
and i have to end the poll now actually
uh the former president uh
encourages people to get vaccinated
okay